سلمى الاجواء تتحدث عن نفسها ان امام كما
تشاهدين عدد كبير من
المحبين كره القدم من الجمهور الذي جاء
ليس فقط من داخل قطر وانما من مختلف في
الحاله العالم لكي يكون شاهدا على ربما
افضل وارقى مونديال في السنوات الاخيره
الذي سيبدا غدا همم طبعا هؤلاء منذ تقريبا
خمس ساعات وهم يعيشون هذه الاجواء قبل ذلك
كانت اغاني خاصه من امريكا اللاتينيه حيث
الجمهور والان اغاني عربيه
نور
انفاسك ربما كان جهدا كبيرا خلال هذا
اليوم هذا المناسب الانجليزي
لم اسمع سؤالك سلمى
ان تكون بحاله جيده وتتحدث بصوره
جيده
[موسيقى]
كبير
مع بعض الزملاء وبعض الاصدقاء
تقريبا ضيف هذه المره من انجلترا وديتيكا
باديس
هذا الجو الاحتفالي بالفعل الاحتفال ومميز
يسعدني ان ارى هذه الباقه من الناس من كل
انحاء العالم كل شيء مميز ماذا بالنسبه
الى حظوظي المنتخب الانجليزي اعتقدوا ان
المنتخب لديه فرصه لديه فرصه بالفعل
استمتع بك كاس العالم شكرا شكرا
تتحدث عن نفسها هذا ما لدينا حتى هذه وهذا
تونسي والكل يريد ان يتحدث الكل يريد ان
يفرح في هذا المساء وطبعا ننتظر المباراه
غدا